sir compulsory jobs for nhs staff why
because first of all let me just thank
nhs and care staff for the amazing work
they do but especially those that have
already chosen
to take that vaccine and they've done
that not only to protect themselves and
their colleagues but most of all they've
taken it to protect their patients and
and that's why that's really at the
heart of this this is about a patient's
safety we know that the vaccines work we
also know that patients in hospital in
care these are some of the most
vulnerable people in our society and if
they are exposed to covert it could be
fatal and i think it's our duty to make
sure that they are safe as they can be
and that's why i announced this
yesterday so that from april next year
that if you work in nhs or care you will
be required to be vaccinated and i want
this to be a positive decision for for
everyone and and to work with them there
will be absolutely no scapegoating no
singling out no shaming but working with
colleagues to support them in every way
that we can to help them make this
positive decision so they can protect
themselves their colleagues and most of
all their patients
yeah but should they lose their job if
they don't want to
i don't want to see anyone lose their
job i don't want to see anyone have to
walk away from their job but i think
that what we all do want to see we want
to see our hospitals
people providing care whether it's in
your home in our care home and we want
those patients those people to be as
safe as possible and now with what we
know about this this horrid virus and
but also that the fact that the vaccines
work i just do think it is important to
be doing everything we can because also
what i don't want to see most of all
what i don't want to see is someone
being exposed to
that's vulnerable being exposed to covid
when it could have been prevented and
perhaps they might even die from that
and i think that would be totally
unacceptable
so if you've been double jabbed then you
can't pass on the virus
no if you've been double jab then you're
less likely to be infected of course you
can still get infected but you're less
likely to and we know that so if you've
had the az jab for instance that we know
that from study after study the the the
the chances of you being affected are uh
65 percent less than they would be
otherwise uh the with the fisa jab it's
about 80 less you're less likely to be
infected and if you are uh know you can
only pass on the virus if you are
infected and and that's why the the
vaccines are so important
yeah but you've got a 37 percent chance
of still passing on covered 19 if you've
got it even if you've been double jabbed
and you know this isn't about perfection
you know there's no it's not really
having an infection
we don't help secretary come on
we don't live in a risk-free world this
this virus we're learning about it all
the time and it's our duty to make sure
that we're doing everything we can
using all the tools that we have to
protect people and what yesterday's
announcement is about is about
protecting some of the most vulnerable
people in our society that we already
know anyone who's in hospital in a
hospital bed they're there because
they're vulnerable they're already ill
there's already some something that's
making them you're ill and vulnerable
and the last thing you want to do is
expose them to this horrible virus if it
can be prevented now i'm not pretending
nobody is that you can have a 100
100 method of of protecting them but
what you can do is reduce the the
chances of them becoming affected and i
think it is perfectly reasonable to say
to everyone that works in health and
care to that you please you take this
vaccine some 93 percent have had at
least one shot and that's fantastic to
see there's still around a hundred
thousand we estimate in the nhs that
have not but over the coming months we
will work with them the nhs will work
with them in the most positive
constructive way to help them make that
positive decision to take the vaccine
yeah 37 chance is still pretty high
though um isn't it would it not be
better what would you what would you
like k would you like a hundred percent
chance you're working
to go on if i may
37 it's 37 chance you say you say it's
quite high but i'll tell you what 80 and
90 chance is a lot higher and i think
your viewers listening to this program
would understand that that this is about
minimizing the risk it's about
minimizing the risk with this virus it's
a horrid virus we sadly we know so many
people that have been affected you may
know i know people i've lost loved ones
to this but lots of people have
listening to this program and i think
what they would expect that if you are
in a vulnerable situation if you're in a
hospital bed you're in a care home
you're at your home receiving
domiciliary care they don't want to know
that that
that care worker that is perhaps
visiting some 10 people that day if they
are
infected and perhaps they're
asymptomatic do you want them going
around every house and infecting 10 of
their people that they're sitting them
of course you don't your viewers don't
want to see that now i'm not saying it
can be 100 i can jump in at some stage
and say i was going to go on right away
you can but i'm only i'm only doing what
you normally do but carry on
if i may uh i was going to say why not
test somebody every day if they're a
frontline worker and then you're 100
sure that they haven't got the virus
we do that anyway the nhs will will do
that in most i don't know
exactly every day but in the nhs and in
care homes people will be tested
regularly precisely for the reason that
you pointed out earlier that when you
take vaccines of course your chance of
being infectious is a lot less but it's
not foolproof and that's why having the
vaccine alongside regular testing is
that is the best way that we can go and
protect everyone in any way that we can
you test people twice a week i believe
in the nhs why not test them every day
i i think that's it's about regular
testing and i'd leave that up to the
clintons
i should i i think the clinicians should
decide how often people need to be
tested and and the types of tests that
are taken but if i think as long as
there is regular testing and people have
taken the vaccine and of course there
are other controls in place in the
hospital other infection controls and
measures i think all these taken
together makes the conditions for those
vulnerable people as safe as they
possibly can be and again that's really
at the heart of yesterday's announcement
it's all about patient safety of course
it will help protect other colleagues in
the nhs and care as well because you
know you don't want the staff to to get
ill if that can be avoided and so
this is what yesterday's announcement is
about
okay what has jeffrey cox done wrong
look i don't want to get into any
individual case especially if i don't
know the details but i i know obviously
the the big issue that you're talking
about i do think it is important that
you're any member of parliament if they
do have any external duties that they
are completely open and transparent
about that i think it is uh important
that their constituents obviously uh
know about that and also that they
engage in no kind of lobbying whatsoever
okay labour's referring to jeffrey cox
to the standards committee for a brazen
beat breach of the rules do you want to
defend him this morning
as i said i'm not going to get into an
individual case i don't know the
individual circumstances of every member
of parliament
all i can say about jeffrey cox is my
time in in government with him when he
was beside me as a cabinet minister he
was a fantastic cabinet minister but in
terms of
these issues i don't know the details
okay let me ask you more generally then
do you feel comfortable with the rules
as they presently stand on mps having
second jobs
i i think the rules as they currently
are in terms of having that flexibility
whether it's a a consultancy type job
whether it perhaps it's an mp that is
still serving in some capacity as a
doctor a nurse or you know i think it's
it's a right that those rules allow that
flexibility but i think the most
important thing really is is that
that mp whoever he or she may be is
completely transparent and open follows
all the rules
and that they're so that their
constituents and and and the wider
public know uh that they might have
another interest but also i think it's
important that they continue to spend
the vast majority of their time on their
parliamentary affairs and their
constituency affairs okay should um
should mps be able to use their office
for uh second job work
no
okay so if they did
what should happen to them
well that's that i i again i i
you might be trying to draw me into some
individual case but if if there are uh
your concerns or you said no there
should be someone believes if someone
believes for a good reason that they
might then i think what they should do
is ask the appropriate authorities to
look into it and they can get down to
the facts
yeah but of course you shouldn't be
using whether it's your parliamentary
office
yeah if it's if it's your
if it's your uh whether it's your
parliamentary office or any other um
parliamentary stationery or anything
that's funded or supported by the
taxpayer of course that should not uh be
used and and again i can't talk about
any individual case i think the rules on
on the use of whether it's parliamentary
property or or or your letters or
letterheads or stamps or anything like
that i think the rules are clear and of
course all mps would be expected to
observe that at all times okay that i'm
not talking about specific cases because
you don't want to uh but if somebody did
use their office for a second job what
should happen to them
no i i don't know the it will depend on
all the circumstances and i'm not the
judge of this nor should i be it should
be independently judged by the
parliamentary standards commissioner so
if there are particular cases then i
will trust the commissioner to look at
that and come to the right decision
um okay well that's that's what jeffrey
cox did apparently but you don't want to
talk about specific cases what i can
talk to you about though is that the
vice chairman andrew barry of the um
conservative party has stepped down um
he says he can't uh he can't cope with
all this sleaze
anymore it doesn't look great does it
when that sort of thing happens
i don't know about that you just share
that information with me but i think
look it's really important that that
parliamentarians whether whichever party
that they're in uh that they are very
clear transparent rules whether it's
around lobbying it's the use of
parliamentary uh property and that they
are held to the very highest of
standards
it's frustrating for you though i'm sure
isn't it given that if
last week um the prime minister had not
forced all of you to support his mate
who subsequently had to step down
because the british public are just not
having it anymore then you know we
wouldn't be in you wouldn't be in this
position would you
as a party
that there's there was a case a
particular case in that case it was the
owen patterson case and uh i i voted for
that motion i do regret it because i
think it was wronger for me to conflate
you know the owen patterson case with
the right of an appeal i do think it's
important to
for parliamentarians on a cross-party
basis to to think about how they might
always be able to improve a system but
it was wrong to conflate it with owen
patterson so i regret having voted for
that i'm glad it's been uh it's
something that is settled now as in i
believe yesterday the government has
brought forward a motion to rescind that
and to accept the owen patterson report
in full and i think that's the right
thing
okay final question before i let you go
back to uh on topic uh for you i'm
reading in the newspaper this morning
that um over 65s in france um will not
be allowed access to um restaurants on
trains etc unless they've had their
booster is that something that you might
look at
we're not looking at that uh yet uh we
are you're very focused on our booster
program as you would imagine over 10.6
million boosts i think
throughout the uk so far already a
record number of bookings many people
coming forward i think in due course uh
we will have to to to look at you know
what constitutes vaccination but at this
point uh the most important thing is
that anyone that's eligible gets out
there and gets their boost
okay you said yet so potentially in the
future
i can't i can't rule that out and uh i
think that we know
now that the vaccines do wane and it's
important that uh that those vaccines
where it's necessary that those people
get a top-up and that's what the booster
program is about but i think it's
something that we have to keep under
review